à deux pas du centre ville de saint
benoît le calme règne dans la rue alexis
de villeneuve
ici le temps à épargner quelques biens
jolis case qui restent à l'abri d'une
luxuriante végétation le temps at il
aussi préserver la mémoire d'alexis 2009
est ce que vous savez qui a été utilisé
et non depuis avant d'y fumer lada
alexis dernière à colombes un politicien
des députés et préfets un écrivain ou
navigateurs h pas c'est un match qu'on
nous à se coller plus exactement des
telles dates à telle date
cette rue autrefois rue de l'église a
été rebaptisé alexis de villeneuve en
1947 en hommage à celui qui avait été
assassiné un an plus tôt mais en 1906 à
saint-benoît d'une grande famille
d'industriels du sucre joseph lucien
alexis vit une enfance heureuse dans la
nature
il suit des études normales et les
traces de son père la politique
à 28 ans à peine il est conseiller
général à 32 il devient maire de sa
ville natale à l'issue d'une séance à
rebondissements puisqu'il aura désigné
successivement deux personnes il
poursuit sa tâche agricole à la tête du
comité de défense des planteurs et
éleveurs de saint benoît
en 1939 il épouse andrée isautier un an
plus tard la deuxième guerre mondiale le
mobilise à son retour le conseil général
est en sommeil et il a été remplacé à la
mairie de saint-benoît
c'est alors qu'il se porte candidat aux
élections législatives
battu d'une courte distance parfois le
vergès il prend la tête du mrp avec le
parti il prépare la prochaine campagne
les soutiens ne manquent pas directeur
de la minoterie de sainte-marie de
lusine des coraux de saint-gilles de la
société industrielle des engagés il
cumule les casquettes
alexis de villeneuve est un homme
puissant
lors d'un meeting le 25 mai 1946 il est
abattu à bout portant